does Boris Johnson tell the truth all
guidance was followed completely during
number 10. denial after Denial in the
strongest possible terms I'm sickened
myself and Furious about that I've been
repeatedly assured that the rules
these words were false but did he know
that whatever happened uh the guidance
was followed and the rules were followed
at all times
those questions are what a committee of
MPS is trying to answer did Boris
Johnson knowingly mislead Parliament
over covid rule breaking in number 10.
today the first sign of their evidence
and Analysis and it's not pretty for the
former prime minister the committee
revealed the issue they want to probe
with Mr Johnson says there is evidence
that the House of Commons may have been
misled a culture of drinking in the
workplace in some parts of number 10
continued after covid restrictions began
Mr Johnson failed to tell the house
about his own knowledge of the
Gatherings that is because there is
evidence that he attended them breaches
of guidance would have been obvious to
Mr Johnson at the time he was at the
Gatherings
yet still Mr Johnson claims he's
innocent
there's no evidence to show that I must
have known right I must have believed
that uh illegal events were taking
places because I didn't and I thought we
were fighting covid to the best of our
ability in very difficult circumstances
in number 10 in the cabinet office uh
night and day but new photos paint a
somewhat different picture Boris Johnson
at events surrounded by people and
alcohol
the MPS investigating him say he must
have known this was breaking the rules
those around Boris Johnson in number 10
were clearly worried about what was
going on in April 2021 so that's before
the stories about what had happened
emerged One Number 10 official wrote
they were worried about leaks of the PM
having a p star star up and to be fair I
don't think it's unwarranted then fast
forward to January of 2022 when some of
the stories had come out and the number
10 official then wrote I'm trying to do
some q a that's a question and answer a
guide to what was going on it's not
going well the director of
communications a political advisor at
that point Jack Doyle wrote I'm
struggling to come up with the way this
one is in the rules in my head
the number 10 official wrote back
reasonably necessary for work purposes
Doyle replied not sure that one works
does it also blows another great gaping
hole in the PM's account doesn't it
the labor leader trying to implicate the
current prime minister too
I think the evidence of wrongdoing by
Boris Johnson is already pretty damning
I think it's important to bear in mind
that Russia sunak at the time was
obviously very close to all of this and
sat on his hands
for those who lost loved ones in the
pandemic the anger is personal Lynn's
husband Gareth died from covid in March
2021. instead of doing the right thing
as I said in acting as a Statesman he is
again trying to cover things up when he
must have known he is the leader of the
country who should be setting an example
to us and I don't believe him I think he
knows he's at fault and he's trying to
cover it up he will appear in just over
two weeks before the committee Boris
Johnson the biggest headache for his
success as brexit plans but he can't
escape questions about his own past
samcoat Sky News